just have fun who gives a [ __ ] like
there's that [ __ ] Missy Elliott song
it's like you think she's really trying
to be racist towards Asians
[Music]
all right so this says uh recently gone
in the news and I just thought it'd be
an interesting conversation I'm going to
report this as an unbiased host it has
nothing to do with my ethnic makeup okay
but
former Royal Meghan Markle has been
slamming Austin Powers and Kill Bill for
promoting negative Asian stereotypes
wait how are they they're not even
[ __ ] new movies all right dude what
are they doing like I said completely
she born when Austin Powers came out
like how old is she she's 41 years old
actually I like that she doesn't say
that Austin Powers is is uh promoting
British stereotypes what about shagging
all the time give a [ __ ] yeah what a
weird Hill to [ __ ] like well so she
is on uh she has a podcast now uh that
has apparently been getting some good
traction the former Duchess of Sussex
that kind of has a flow to it
um basically it went to her podcast to
uh promote this latest episode called
Asian stereotypes why she slammed is she
the only one talking about it
do you have a guest she did have guests
and these are these are very good guests
actually uh she had a Margaret Cho uh
and Lisa Ling oh Lisa Lee I trust the
[ __ ] out of Lisa totally trust Lisa I
like Margaret show too so what did they
have to say they basically got on the
episode to talk about you know
disassembling the anti-aging slurs in
Los Angeles uh Marco roasted the two
decade old films for presenting
caricatures of women in Asian descent
the former actor was specifically
referring to Gold Member which features
Japanese woman fuk me portrayed by Diane
mizoda and fuku played by Karen what a
good bit those are pretty funny though
it was very funny
uh I didn't like all the Dutch
stereotypes in that movie there it is
you know it from coming from you that's
totally this is a safe space I didn't
like it at all thanks for sharing thank
you for sharing a pancake
Blitz uh and then Tarantino's 2003 cult
hit Kill Bill start Lucy Liu as the
murderously violent Yakuza leader Oren
ishi that was a dope character why was
that one bad why was why was that a
negative stereotype yeah was that the
whole point so she says movies like
Austin Powers and Kill Bill presented
these characters of Asian women as
oftentimes over sexualized or aggressive
and it's not just that's accurate have
you ever met an Asian Mom they're very
aggressive it is and over sexualized but
the weird thing is Quentin Tarantino's
movies are usually based on existing
characters from older films yeah yeah so
like the oranishi character is a Trope
like from like old Cinema and it's it's
also Witcher Japanese movies and Anime
is hella hella like that bro yeah like
animes is hella [ __ ] sexual yeah
Lauren ishi's bit was an animated yeah
the whole movie of Kill Bill was so
stylized I get the Austin Powers one
because that's just a [ __ ] joke like
but everybody every race in Austin
Powers is a joke so like okay but then
it sucks that people are still being fuk
me and fuku for Halloween
granted really he's doing that it
doesn't suck for the guys who are with
me and food yeah dude they're killing
dude those outfits those outfits are
fire they're getting laughs but the Kill
Bill thing is like if if they made
oranishi white they would be like she
should have been Asian yeah you can't
win dude you can't make everybody why
why does Meghan Markle even give a [ __ ]
though that's like me like talking about
[ __ ] British stereotypes well it's
not it's not that she gets a [ __ ] she
was asking Margaret Cho and and uh Lisa
Lisa they give that's her podcast right
and her topics well I mean I I could see
you know you bring on different guests
uh to to talk about the things that
maybe they give a [ __ ] about oh I see
but I'm not saying they're the ones
specifically Who are slanting Austin
Powers and it just came up in
conversation yeah it just came I think
there's a there's enough whack [ __ ] in
today's movies then you know you don't
gotta go back that far yeah two decades
is pretty far I think one decade you
gotta leave it alone I thought they
[ __ ] like in for the most part like
mainstream movies kind of learned from
that a little bit like you're not gonna
see you know Fook me a [ __ ] spin-off
but what would that look like though
what would that look like how uh I think
they're like remember we were talking
about someone was bringing out how Mean
Girls is racist Asians yeah yeah yeah
and we were like yo there's so much like
get the [ __ ] that's out now because
those guys haven't learned yeah you know
but what's a good example of something
that's out now that they would have
um something to talk about as far as
like Asia negative Asian stereotypes I
was us I just saw not something that's
out now but I did crack up this morning
while I was taking a [ __ ] because I just
saw one of those memes uh of an old clip
from this uh the scary movie where
um what's their face
um oh yeah Anna Faris Anna Faris is
looking at the [ __ ] the ring or The
Grudge kid oh yeah they're just saying
like Honda Suzuki you know Toshiba
Yamaha that's that's what's funny that's
the American stupid view of what agents
sound like it's satire yeah they're not
trying to make a like the even as hacky
as that is that's the joke they're
trying to that's what the joke was yeah
it's like Simpsons Simpsons is not
Simpsons is not making fun of Asians or
or Indians or anything they're making
fun of how Americans are so dumb that we
see it that way and everyone's getting
it too it's not just an Asian [ __ ]
thing yeah but some people really don't
see past that and they just go oh
they're making fun of Indians or they're
making fun of Asians it's like dude yeah
they're making fun of you how you see
this everyone can get these jokes that's
how we have to think about it I will say
it's really funny uh has anybody ever
been watching a um house of the Dragon
yeah so with House of the Dragon uh
people are more or less familiar with
the sword okay I think it's obviously
funny that um there's nothing but a lot
of like you know uh I'm married to my
cousin so we're supposed to Bear
children for the Royal Line and whatnot
but obviously I'm [ __ ] this other
dude on the side and now my children
look like this other dude right so they
do this whole thing about how it's like
oh it's not the same hair color like
obviously if you're [ __ ] Valerian the
hair is supposed to be like white and
blonde but your hair is like brunette
but at the end of the day it's like all
the valerians are actually black people
in the show so it's like it's not really
about the hair it's like also about the
skin color like they made it as clear as
possible even though it's really like
um also kind of gray you don't really
it's not a skin thing nobody mentions it
even though all the valerians are black
basically no one says it yeah it's it's
it's it's just as clear as possible to
show the differentiation but it's not
really talked about in order to be like
sensitive enough and it's just uh it's
actually pretty tactful but I feel like
that's an example of like today's world
and realm of entertainment and
storytelling being adaptive to the
sensitivity without being like so
head-on that like 30 years from now you
can look at it and be like that's a
problem I feel like everybody's trying
to work so perfectly in the realm of
artistic uh appropriate yeah while not
being like not pissing anybody off I
also think everything's so [ __ ] lame
yeah because everyone's so like [ __ ]
careful and [ __ ] you know where it's
like where the camera voice just have
fun who gives a [ __ ] like there's that
[ __ ] Missy Elliott song
it's like you think really trying to be
racist towards Asians or she's just not
what that was or she's having a good
time in the [ __ ] Studio I don't know
but like why are you why does what does
that have to do with me that was an
Asian dude because people people will do
that right like kind of with this whole
thing like oh my God I know what Mike
Myers was thinking about yeah he wanted
to [ __ ] me over it's like no [ __ ] they
don't even know who the [ __ ] you are
yeah like everything that's so like
hyper fixated yeah like I know who
they're trying to offend and it worked
I'm like they don't even know what I
think they should shift their focus to
is not especially Meghan Markle I think
Meghan Markle shouldn't shift her Focus
to these Asian films they should be
talking about the beguiled the film Easy
pal you know what I mean like that's
what they should be just hey that's his
people dude watch out just like look
over there and see why is Clint Eastwood
kissing a 12 year old that's gonna be
13. because he's playing a character
also
um
is to try and look at it from the other
perspective like
for us especially like you know we we've
been here before in this exact same room
and talked about things like this
obviously being in the realm of
entertainment obviously being associated
with the Asian race
um we've talked about things like this
but uh what about like maybe her fans
that are like super about her that don't
pay attention to any of this [ __ ] and
maybe that aren't Asian yeah that's you
know what I'm saying that will take
whatever she says tooth and nail for the
most part because they're already
subscribed to her like what about those
people that maybe could use a
potentially eye-opening conversation
with a credible person like Margaret Cho
or Lisa Lee I think it's cool I think
it's cool to point these These past
things out in order to cite the source
of why we don't do that [ __ ] no more
like that's cool like when you look at
16 Candles now people are like what's a
classic and then you have the [ __ ]
long duck dong character like I get that
like but then also to know that it's
confined to that era totally
understandable you look at movies from
like the in the beginning of Cinema and
women are always having hysteria getting
slapped and step out of it in the movie
that's the answer to the problem but we
don't look at that now and go oh that's
reflective of society today no it's like
oh they used to do that because they
didn't [ __ ] know better I'm a little
bit the opposite you know they're like
let's create more rules so like the
basketball players are safer I'm like
how do we take the rules away so it
could be more like football
you know so like let's take away less of
the rules you want more CTE and then we
have way more racist movies that are way
funner yeah just race like you just
[ __ ] attack like Indian attacks white
white attacks Asian attacks [ __ ]
everyone just [ __ ] gets it and then
we vote with our [ __ ] Edward Cinemas
tickets you guys remember you guys
remember when Sean Connery was getting
interviewed by like Diane Sawyer and
he's and he's just very plainly she's
like she's like you know you're hitting
a lot of women in these movies and he's
like some women could use a slap in the
mouth yeah right
and then everyone thought he was like
the worst human being yeah he's like
well no back then I think it wasn't even
that controversial it was like maybe a
little bit controversial but then
everyone in America was kind of like
yeah I mean yeah but nowadays they're
like oh my God I can't believe he said
that time's changed see that's I want to
see more of that I can't believe what
they were trying to cancel Casablanca
that was that was crazy yeah it cost
longer that's that's one of the ones I
was basically talking about like when
you look at old film well what happened
in costume they're slapping the [ __ ] out
of women
I don't even remember that part also
they you know just like their depiction
of like slavery and stuff like that
right or not slavery they had like a uh
basically a black like helper yeah but
uh maybe the butler type of role but I
think they're just like people are just
really offended about the portrayal uh
and the constant portrayal and depiction
you know what I mean minorities in that
way so they're trying to just [ __ ] go
all the way back take them all out
Castle them all and then erase the
history of this kind of discrimination
it definitely sucks to see that I'm sure
like if you're black and you're seeing
that and you're like dude [ __ ] this it's
like the same way when you have but then
inversely today when you have like a
Chinese film the helper's [ __ ]
Filipino it's like that's right now you
know what I mean but then the thing is
that's still a true frequency you can go
to China you will see a Filipino helper
honestly it doesn't make us look great
it kind of sucks to feel but then it's
still you know there's some truth to it
to the character you want the truth out
there don't you right well I mean yeah
just don't different kinds of truths
as far as from a film to understand that
like oh yeah this is a thing that
happens yeah like it's for us to ignore
it is like the only thing that sucks is
if that's the only thing that you ever
are is the helper like that's why it
sucks yeah that's true but then still
like in terms of old Cinema like I
totally understand looking at it and
going yeah [ __ ] this today it's a time
capsule right that's why my favorite
genre of movies where white people are
helping out the minorities big time
which movies are those I like The Blind
Side and it's like
hey man that's so quick
the funny thing is if you think like
movies in America are racist then you
haven't seen [ __ ] foreign films where
America's the bad guy yeah like that's
pretty heavy to see that [ __ ] for the
first time like if you don't know how
other countries view the US watch a
Chinese film like yeah or like watch a
Chinese film that where America is the
villain and you'll be like no
but it's like bro that's when you you
can't just limit racism and film to just
America like every country has their
view of another country it's always
going to be racist to you about America
yeah good old North Korea I heard the
craft service is pretty good on North
Korea
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]